let's now go to Donald Trump on the
issue of the government shutdown I love
a good instance of old-fashioned
hypocrisy and we all know that
big-picture Americans blame Trump and
the Republicans for the government
shutdown that's going on as I told you
earlier Trump shutdown has been trending
on Twitter Republicans control the house
they control the Senate they control the
White House and Republicans have been
scrambling to figure out who to blame
but I think that if Trump is involved in
this shutdown and he is he's the
president right now why don't we go back
to what Trump himself said about who
should we blame when there is a
government shutdown I'm going to play
for you here a clip of Donald Trump in
2013 when President Barack Obama was in
the Oval Office and Trump explained who
do you blame when the government shuts
down who's gonna take the blame down I
mean in a boardroom here who's getting
fired
who's gonna bear the brunt of the
responsibility if indeed there is a
shutdown of our government well let me
say who gets fired it always has to be
the top I mean problems start from the
top and they have to get solved from the
top and the president's the leader and
he's got to get everybody in a room and
he's got to lead you know the
interesting thing is in 25 years and 50
years and a hundred years from now when
the government is you know what they
talk about the government shutdown you
know they're gonna be talking about the
President of the United States who was
the president at that time they're not
gonna be talking who the head of the
house was the head of the Senate who's
running things in Washington so I really
think the pressure is on the president
Wow
quite eloquent right but of course Trump
now is blaming Democrats for the
shutdown despite that they are totally
and completely out of power
what did Trump previously say about how
the opposition party should handle
shutdowns and negotiations around
shutdowns well let's go to the record
Donald Trump tweeted in October of 2013
it is crucial for Republicans to remain
united during this shutdown which is
sort of what Pat pointed out in the
first segment the Democrats are doing
right now but when Democrats do it and
Trump is the president it's a whole new
set of rules
what about claims that Democrats are
unfairly tying another political issue
in this case it's daca to the shutdown
well Trump doesn't like it now but he
seemed to like it when Republicans did
it in 2013 having tweeted in September
of 2013 congratulations to Speaker
Boehner Boehner whoa excuse me Freudian
slip there on standing strong and tying
government shutdown to defunding
Obamacare Republicans tying the shutdown
to Obamacare that's good Democrats
saying let's get the daca thing figured
out that's bad all of a sudden so what's
the trend here and not just in this
story but in the trump presidency at
large the trend is how can I say this
Trump doing exactly what he criticized
Obama for doing or Hillary Clinton for
doing during the campaign everything
that Trump is thought they were voting
against by voting for Trump they ended
up voting for even more Bigley than they
could have imagined but at least Trump
is pro-life right oh yeah well I guess
for the last two years he's been
pro-life first 69 years of his life he
was pro-choice but the last two years
he's been pro-life so I guess he gets a
pass for everything from the trumpet and
also where's the art of the deal here I
thought this wasn't gonna happen under a
great negotiator like Donald Trump and
it's especially because he won't even
lay out what his policy position is on
immigration he doesn't know he doesn't
know what it is in the last 10 days he
said to Dianne Feinstein front would do
a clean daca bill that was immediately
stricken struck stricken from the Trant
White House transcript until it was
pointed out that hey Trump did say that
then it was added back in he said if you
put a bipartisan deal in front of me
just put any bipartisan deal in front of
me I'll sign it he didn't end up signing
it look how many positions has he taken
on immigration in the last two weeks
Chuck Schumer offered him authorization
to fund the wall go which he turned down
yeah I wasn't good enough for him III
really don't get it and I don't know how
long the shutdown will go it might be
over by the time you hear this it might
go a little longer we'll see but what we
are sort of coming around to is people
need to vote do government shutdowns get
people to vote one way or the
there I actually don't know the answer
to that I don't know particularly when
we're you know nine ten months out from
the election I just don't know if people
vote based on who they perceived to have
shut down the government well
Republicans were blamed for shutting
down the government in 2013 and yet they
did well in the 2014 midterms so yeah at
least if you look at that bit of history
I don't know if it'll be that
consequential for them yeah I just I
just don't know if it's a voting issue
but I'm curious what you think I'm on
Twitter at D Pakman the show is on
twitter at david pakman show and we've
got a big a big league broadcast for you
today glad you're with us today's
episode of the david pakman show is made
possible in part by brilliant you watch
the David Pakman show so you're probably
interested in politics you follow what's
going on in the world with the economy
the environment but what's crucial to
understand is that almost everything we
talk about on the program is sort of
underscored by or based on math science
and philosophy and keeping up with the
news is one thing but you're never
really fully equipped to understand
political issues and have debates with
people substantive debates until you've
developed a more full understanding of
how the world works and how these issues
at work at the most sort of fundamental
level and brilliant is one of the most
effective and enjoyable ways to do that
that I've ever come across you can learn
hands-on about statistics crime climate
science energy it's a very long list of
topics and you can get started right now
by signing up for free at brilliant org
slash David Pakman and the first 200
people who visit brilliant org slash
David Pakman we'll get 20% off an annual
premium membership one more time that's
brilliant org forward slash David Pakman